I know we just learned a lot of new terminology,
but hopefully you're able to breeze right through this one.
Now we have three scenarios, a lot of transcription, a
medium amount of transcription, and no transcription. If we need
to match the scenario on the right with the scenario
on the left, so which scenario on the left would
give us, let's say the least amount of transcription. Well,
obviously if our silencer is bound, that silence is transcription.
Enhancer enhances transcription. So if we've silenced our
transcription and we don't have anything to help
enhance, this is probably the scenario which we're
going to have little to no transcription at
all. The scenario above it, however, we have
the enhancer bound and the silencer's unbound. Remember
the proteins mitigate the effects ,of what these
non-coding regions can do. So a bound enhancer is
going to enhance transcription, an unbound silencer won't be
able to silence transcription. And so this is going to be
our most active transcription here, lots of transcription. So
the answer to this one is A. And that leaves
this last scenario, where we don't have a bound
enhancer, we don't have a bound silencer. The promoter is
left to initiate whatever transcription it can on its
own. And so we reach the scenario of some transcription.
It depends entirely on the promoter region itself. But in general, there's
going to be some transcription that happens at the site. But because there's no
enhancer or silencer bound, we're not going to have these extremes show
up, where we have a lot
of transcription happening, or no transcription happening.